hi well my name is pete hanlon and i'm
the cto at moneypenny and we are the
number one outsource communications
provider in the world
so so moneypenny is all about
conversations and people
our mission as a business is to make
every conversation better than the last
and to build
systems that work in synergy with rpas
so to do that we need systems
that can unlock voice through speech to
text
understand context and intensive
conversations which is why we need to
use tools like ai in deep learning
so
to the biggest challenge that we were
facing was
unlocking insight from the conversations
that we capture um that's always been a
big challenge for us very much uh
all that insight is locked into those
conversations and we wanted to release
it so for example recently
we wanted to identify
conveyancing calls so we could
understand some trends in the property
sector
and in order to do that
we had to process
a year's worth of conversations to get
good trend information we need at least
a year
and doing that normally would be a
really slow process due to the volumes
of data involved
so that's why
we reached out to hugging face and look
to use infinity and auto nlp to help us
in that process
we used auto nlp to create
a model based on 12 months worth of
anonymized conversations
the the process was really
straightforward we uploaded
the training data
and after about 30 minutes we had a
model a winning model that could
identify conveyancing conversations with
over 98
accuracy all we did was upload the data
and and it chose the best model
98 accuracy
uh the models were automatically loaded
into model hub
and immediately ready for us to use our
code
so in total i'm as a huge time saver
normally that is something that would
take us days to get the best model and
to optimize
so the process of setting up infinity
was really slick
it only took about 50 minutes in total
we we had to register hugging face
against our aws container registry
then we just used docker to pull the
infinity image nice and simple
and when we run infinity it's
automatically downloaded our new model
they've been optimized from the model
hub and then we're up and running
so from my experience
productionizing deep learning models can
be a real challenge but this was a super
slick process
so we were able to process a year's
worth of conversations
in just over an hour
which is a massive improvement on
performance
normally that would take about 10 hours
10 11 hours
um we were running infinity on a nvidia
t4 gpu in the amazon cloud
and we could see it was taking about
four milliseconds to classify a
conversation which is amazing so it just
rattled through the conversations
so the great thing for us as a business
is that using infinity and auto nlp
we can process data much faster
and we can quickly train new models
and from a business perspective that
means we get insight faster
and we release the value of our data
faster
so
i think the the sweet spot is
um
where there's a lot of
data to process or where there's a
requirement for real-time systems and
that's that's where we see this
being useful in money penny going
forward is around
more real-time processing
but i think there's another scenario
here around
using infinity for
solving the concurrency problem so if
you're building apis or web apps
and
you don't want to take on the challenge
of building highly concurrent systems
that deal with um deep learning models
use infinity instead and it just takes
away all that pain
you